♪ ♫ Musique de suspense ♪ ♫
NON !
Voilà je me permets de répondre au titre
NON
Voilà, c'est NON
Pour ceux qui se demandent de quoi je parle, avec Norman on a imaginé une mini-série
qui s’appelle "Presque adultes"
Et qui sera diffusée cet été à la télé et sur YouTube
"Et toi alors la vie ça va ? Ça se passe bien sur YoubiToube ?"
♪ ♫ Musique de la bande annonce ♪ ♫
Cette mini-série a été financée par TF1 et Fanta
Et le premier épisode va être diffusé attention...
Le samedi 8 juillet à 20h45 à la télévision,
et 2 semaines plus tard, sur YouTube
Et depuis que ça a été annoncé en fait il s'est dit tout et n’importe quoi sur Internet !
Alors moi je vais répondre aux commentaires maintenant...
"Il quitte YouTube pour la télé..."
Bah non !
Non, puisque comme je l'ai dit la série sera aussi sur YouTube
et c'était très important pour nous, c'était même une condition
si la série ne pouvait pas être sur YouTube on ne la faisait pas. Non.
Et surtout ça n'a rien changé à mes vidéos en fait je continue comme d'habitude
Ça c'est juste un projet (euh) supplémentaire, à côté
C'est cadeau c'est gratuit ça me fait plaisir. C'est pour vous.
Ah non mais j'insiste !
Ah généreux ! (Roohh merci Cyprichou)
Ça parle de quoi "Presque Adultes" ?
On est trois personnages : Natoo, Norman et moi-même
On joue un peu nos propres personnages et on parle de notre difficulté à être des adultes
"Moi j'veux pas de gamin, j'saurais même pas m'en occuper !"
"T'a qu'à t'entraîner !"
"Oh c'est un bon bébé !"
Par exemple y'a un épisode où Norman doit garder sa nièce
Un épisode où Natoo est à un repas de famille
Un épisode où ma mère dans la série veut jeter mes jouets d'enfant et ça, ça me fait mal au cœur ;(
On voulait raconter le décalage qu'il y avait entre nos parents qui nous prennent toujours pour des gamins
"Le petit Cyprien ! Celui qui mangeait ses crottes de nez !"
Et les jeunes qui nous prennent pour des vieux
D'où le titre "Presque adultes"
C'est catchy euh...
Y'a plein de personnages, y'a plein de décors, y'a plein de petites aventures
On parle pas du tout de notre métier de Youtubeur
On parle vraiment de nous en tant que jeunes adultes
qui galérons, voilà, avec nos parents, avec les jeunes...
"Ils vont poster moins de trucs sur YouTube ?"
Alors pas du tout !
Non. Même pour ma part c'est même le strict inverse
J'ai prévu plein plein de choses sur ma chaîne YouTube : des courts métrages et même un petit projet secret
qui est prévu pour cet été j'en dis pas plus
#ProjetSecret
L’ÉPOPÉE TEMPORELLE (ne me remerciez pas)
"Ils perdent leur indépendance à la télévision"
Ça c'est très intéressant parce que je sais pas comment ça se passe pour les autres séries
Mais en tout cas nous ni Fanta ni TF1 nous à fait de retours sur les scénarios
Ils ont pas changé une seule virgule on était totalement libre
On a écrit ça avec : Norman, FloBer et Julien Josselin
Entre gars du net tout simplement et puis surtout c'était une aventure super intéressante à vivre
Deux semaines de tournage avec Natoo, avec Norman
C'était un peu intense mais c'était super intéressant
et puis on à fait plein de rencontres j'en ai un très bon souvenir
J'ai hâte que ça sorte !
"c diféren d sketch youtube"
Oui c'est vrai on a voulu tester quelque chose de nouveau
Ecrire une continuité sur dix épisodes, la même thématique avec des personnages
qui avancent dans leurs histoires
En quoi c'est différent ? On joue déjà des personnages plus crédibles
Y'a pas des punchlines tout le temps, un montage énervé avec des zoom comme ça
Des titrages qui apparaissent
POURQUOI ?
Hey j'porte une perruque !
♩♫ Jingle perruque ♩♫
Voilà ce sera pas ça du tout
Et surtout cette série c'est une collaboration
Y'a un réalisateur
Y'a un monteur
Y'a une production
Y'a quelqu'un qui a composé la musique sur le générique
C'est une grande équipe qui à fait ça
Ça c'est "Presque adultes" et ensuite si vous voulez des trucs que j'fais tout seul ça c'est plus mes vidéos tout seul
"Ils ont vendu leur âme à la télé"
Mais t'écoute depuis tout à l'heure ?
En plus tu me ressemble beaucoup et voilà c'est blessant
"Super ! Du contenu supplémentaire, je regarderai tous les épisodes de Presque adultes chaque semaine."
Merci !
Ça c'est quelqu'un de bien
Qui me ressemble énormément aussi c'est vrai
Je vous donne donc rendez vous le samedi 8 juillet à 20h45 pour le premier épisode
Et 2 semaines plus tard sur YouTube
N'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air devant votre télé ou devant Internet, voilà
Ou même dans la rue si vous me croisez un p'tit pouce en l'air
Et moi je vous en dis plus très rapidement sur ce petit projet top secret... voilà
♪ ♫ Musique du générique ♪ ♫
Ça c'était le générique en exclusivité juste pour toi
Et maintenant ce que tu vas faire c'est que tu vas cliquer sur le bouton au milieu. Ouais tu clique sur ton smartphone, avec ton doigt
Et tu pourras t'abonner
Et comme ça tu pourras voir toutes mes prochaines vidéos, le projet secret, la série "Presque adultes"
Vas y clique sur ton smartphone vas y, vas y, CLIQUE !!! Clypso